dans le reste de l'actualité je vous le
disais la journée internationale de
lutte pour les droits des femmes et ceux
tristes constats selon l'ONU l'égalité
femme homme ne sera pas atteinte avant
300 ans alors en ce 8 mars de nombreuses
animations ont eu lieu à travers notre
territoire pour revendiquer plus
d'égalité retour d'abord sur ce
rassemblement organisé dans le
centre-ville tour enjaux par le réseau
féministe 37 pour répéter que le monde
ne peut pas tourner sans femme Léa
Turquie
égalité le maître mot de cette
manifestation du 8 mars le cortège
s'élance depuis la place Anatole France
de Tours près de 1000 personnes se sont
réunies les manifestants sont nombreux
et les revendications aussi plus d'un
tiers des femmes ont déjà vécu une
situation de non consentement et dans un
pays comme le nôtre je trouve ça
scandaleux il y a encore énormément de
choses à faire à ce sujet là c'est
redonner l'importance de la voix des
femmes qui est oubliée qui est qui est
qui est mise de côté qui est trop
souvent
manquée comme aussi fiable que les
hommes nous avons nous
nos opinions et elles sont toutes aussi
importantes du peuple absolument tout le
monde
[Applaudissements]
égalité salariale prise en compte des
opinions des femmes précarité partage de
la charge mentale la journée
internationale de lutte pour les droits
des femmes rassemblent et fédères toutes
les générations et tous les horizons
pour un même combat on est toujours pas
à égalitaire et que il y a encore
énormément
[Musique]
de clous de pression masculines tous les
jours et c'est manifester mais aussi se
rejoindre et se rendre compte qu'on est
pas toute seule c'est tous les jours qui
a des problèmes au boulot et tout mais
de toute façon c'est tous ensemble qu'il
faudra se bagarrer qu'il faut se
bagarrer c'est une vraie injustice que à
l'époque où on est dans le monde on vit
où il y a tellement de biens qui devrait
être partagés et égalitairement c'est
inadmissible selon l'INSEE en 2020 les
hommes gagnent en moyenne 527 euros brut
de plus par mois que les femmes si le 8
mars s'achève la lutte pour les droits
elle continue